let's bring in stephen miller he's
former white house senior adviser to
president trump good morning stephen
thank you for being with us
today in the last couple of days we've
noticed that the biden administration
has begun to describe what's happening
at the southern border as
a normal seasonal surge nothing greatly
outpacing
what happened under the trump
administration that defies some
first-hand
accounts we're witnessing right there
and by the way the numbers that we've
seen what's your reaction to this
well it's very stupid in politics to say
something
that will be disproven with data that's
going to be released in a matter of days
and so at the at the end of the month
they're going to release the
monthly border statistics and what
you're going to see is the largest
number of unaccompanied minors
apprehended since the data
has been kept just to put this in
perspective
during the unaccompanied minor surge
that we all remember very well
in 2014 right that was the first year
that people really
came in large numbers as unaccompanied
under the age of 18
illegally across our borders for the
whole year
the total was 68 000 just shy of 70 000
or about 190 people today
right now they're apprehending in this
age demographic between
six and 800 people a day more than
four times what was happening in that
terrible crisis that we remember
in 2014 there's no precedent not just in
our country
i would argue there's no precedent in
world history
for a resettlement of young people
illegally entering a country
on this scale and who's going to pay for
it all who's going to provide the health
care
who's going to provide the education
who's going to provide the housing the
answer is
hard-working u.s taxpayers who just been
through a global pandemic
stephen uh the the biden administration
would say well
we're this is in the name of humanity
this is in the name
of of a different approach than that
harsh approach
of the trump administration what do you
say to their claims that
hey this is okay even though it's
unprecedented maybe they don't admit
that
because we're being humane yeah so let's
take the example that was brought up at
the press conference
that joe biden did on thursday so
a reporter for another news outlet asked
joe biden about a story
the story was that an unaccompanied
minor
9 years old came here the parents
were back in their home country under
biden's administration that child
separation
is being perpetuated they will be
resettled in the united states
they will be kept away from their
parents they will stay here
indefinitely they may go years even
longer without ever seeing their parents
again
that's joe biden's policy the trump
administration policy
was to contact the home country contact
social services
contact our embassy and consulates and
arrange for a reunification
in the home country and then to work
with that government
to make sure that family was safe that's
the difference joe biden is splitting up
families
all over the world for years at a time
to bring them here to america
at taxpayer expense donald trump was
humanely reuniting people at home
and the termination of that policy the
decision to keep all illegal aliens
under 17 here in america indefinitely
is triggering a title surge that we have
never seen before
again as long as data has been kept
stephen i want to ask you you know we
have two problems here which is that
people are continuing to come
and then you have the people that are
already here so even if president biden
were to come out at this point and say
stop coming or you will be sent back the
question is one
do those people believe him because all
the people that just came
are are likely going to be able to stay
i would assume
and secondly is that enough and does
that address the problem we have now
which is overcrowding a facility what
happens to all of these people now
what do we do right so so a couple
things
first of all joe biden has the authority
right now
under what you may have heard is called
title 42 it's the cdc public health
authority
that donald trump put into place and you
could take all of the unaccompanied
minors that are in facilities today
and begin the process of lining up
charter flights and setting them back to
their home countries
once you do that the overcrowding will
disappear
within days and they will stop coming
and the problem will be solved it is a
voluntary choice of this administration
secondly to your point
the rhetoric is meaningless when it is
contradicted by
reality and so the people that are
getting in not just minors
but thousands upon thousands of adults
traveling with children as well are
being released
when they get in they go onto social
media they report how they got in where
they got in where they are now
and that information travels back to
where they come from so unless you
change the reality
then this mass illegal resettlement is
going to continue
not only at its current unprecedented
pace but to reach even greater highs
that we can scarcely imagine
stephen miller fascinating insight this
morning thank you so much thank you for
having me on
thank you